[Music]
[Music]
when asked why the geography of the
kingdom of hyrule found in the zelda
series changes so radically from game to
game
while locations with the same names keep
popping up yet with completely different
aesthetics and even geographical
locations
nintendo's blatant answer is that it
simply makes each individual game more
interesting to explore
in a franchise with this many
installments having the exact same
overworld map with the exact same
looking lake hylia death mountain and
gerudo desert would no doubt become
tiresome and repetitive
the similar names are simply there to
give seasoned players some sense of
familiarity when the reason behind a
major inconsistency is that it makes the
games more interesting
aka it purely exists for game design
reasons this answer can be a tough pill
to swallow for a zelda theorist
as it is their job or passion to try and
make sense of this universe
and piece together its overarching
history find consistencies or
explanations for the lack thereof and
uncover the mysteries and secrets hiding
in this world
nintendo clearly wants us to do the
thinking a significant portion of the
series accepted lore such as the
infamous timeline
is inspired and even shaped by its fans
and it becomes obvious that the people
behind these amazing games
themselves have a hard time keeping up
with their own established lore
resulting in changes in the narrative
retcons inconsistencies and paradoxes
all throughout the series
zelda lore will never be perfect but
that won't stop fans from continuing to
work on this puzzle
even if the explanations presented
aren't always definitive or watertight
and today we are doing exactly that even
though we already know the answer as to
why hyrule keeps changing we will
attempt to come up with ideas that
circumvent the aspect of game design and
turn it into something that can be
explained without breaking the fourth
wall we will mostly focus on hyrule
though in some cases other kingdoms or
locations outside the borders of the
kingdom will be referenced but not
explored on a deeper level as most of
these don't have a history spanning
across multiple games and thus we have
no idea about their past or future
with all that said let's dive into the
history and geography of the kingdom
of hyrule
when talking about hyrule we have to
start at the very beginning
before time began before spirits and
life existed
three goddesses of power wisdom and
courage descended from the heavens to
create
order out of chaos giving birth to a
world with a physical form
laws and finally spirits and life-forms
to uphold sad laws
there seems to be a misconception that
the goddesses only created hyrule and
due to the wording in some of the
backstories told
this misconception is understandable
however hyrule
is just one of many locations that
exists within this world the goddesses
didn't just create hyrule but in fact
well everything this includes any
location that exists on the same
physical plane as hyrule places like
holodrum lebron and hytopia but also
those that exist in other realms or
dimensions such as the sacred realm
twilight realm termina and more though
each of these worlds and dimensions
usually have their own cultures and
guardian deities
it all ultimately ties back to the
original three goddesses of creation
upon departing back to the heavens the
creators leave behind a symbol of their
power
a relic consisting of three sacred
triangles each one representing one of
the three goddesses virtues
additionally the creators gave life to a
divine being by the name of hylia also
known as her grace or goddess hylia
though not as omnipotent and powerful as
the creators themselves
in their absence she would serve the
role of the highest being in this world
and thus the triforce was left in her
care rumors of the existence of the
triforce
quickly spread amongst the population
and it was said that those who managed
to obtain the holy relic are bestowed
upon the power to make
any wish come true due to its tempting
nature it quickly became the most sought
after object in existence
and it didn't take long for the
inhabitants of the world to start
fighting amongst each other over its
possession
wars ensued and the triforce would be
hidden sealed
split into pieces and re-obtained
multiple times throughout history
enter the very first story in the
chronology of the zelda series
skyward sword a game which actually
takes place in two different eras due to
the advent of time travel
to get a better picture let's start by
outlining some of the most important
events that took place during these two
eras
the rise of the demon tribe under the
command of demise also known as the
demon king who seeks to eradicate every
living being in the world and secure his
total domination through the use of the
triforce making this the very first
conquest for the holy relic
goddess hylia sends the surviving human
population along with the triforce
up into the skies on a piece of landmass
later known as skyloft to keep them out
of harm's way and prevent the relic from
falling into the hands of the demon
tribe
hylia herself remains on the surface to
wage war against the demon king
resulting in his temporary defeat
through the use of a seal placed on him
knowing this seal won't last long hylia
strives to use the triforce to eradicate
the mice once and for all but because
the triforce cannot be used by the hands
of divine beings
she assumes a mortal form by fusing her
soul with a vessel or spirit maiden this
maiden being the very first incarnation
of zelda whose future descendants will
continue to pass on the essence of the
goddess through their bloodline
additionally we see the rise of the very
first knight or hero
chosen by the goddess that being the
very first incarnation of link
we see the birth of the master sword a
sword forged with the sole purpose of
striking down
and sealing away demise were he to
succeed in breaking free from his seal
we witnessed the first iteration of time
travel through the use of portals known
as the gates of time
this is also the first time the triforce
is used that being link who wishes for
the destruction of demise
and finally the defeat and sealing a way
of demise inside the master sword but
not before uttering a devastating curse
one that causes a never-ending cycle an
incarnation of his hatred which shall
ever follow the goddess and chosen hero
and their descendants
until the end of time this hatred will
later manifest in the form of ganondorf
and possibly other beings such as vati
and maladus as well though that last
part is still unconfirmed
at this point now here's where we need
to make a clear distinction
during this era the land where this
battle between hylia and demise takes
place
is already known as hyrule though mind
you this is not yet the kingdom of
hyrule as we come to know it later
the royal family of hyrule has not been
established at this point and it's
likely that during this era people were
still living in tribes segregated from
one another despite this
we do see the first familiar names pop
up in hyrule's geography
names like eldon pharaon in la neru
named after the three dragon spirits who
watch over each of their respective
province and whose names are obviously
derived from the original three golden
goddesses
din faror and nehru we will eventually
see the names of these provinces and
even the dragon spirits themselves make
a return
in later games aside from the provinces
names like lake hylia
death mountain and gerudo desert are
still absent at this point in time
some notable locations we do find are
the seal temple
also known as the temple of hylia and
the temple of time now here is where it
gets a bit confusing the temple of time
we find here which is located in the
leneru desert is not at all linked to
the same one we find in later games
it's an unrelated structure which bears
the same name probably because this is
where the first gate of time was located
before hylia destroys it during one of
her escapes to the past
the gate of time is what allows link and
his friends to travel between their own
time period and around a thousand years
ago when demise was only recently sealed
by hylia link later learns of the
existence of a second gate of time which
will be assembled inside the seal temple
this temple is also where the master
sword is laid to rest at the very end of
the game
another important thing to outline are
the most prominent races which exist in
this time period that being the people
of skyloft also known as skyloftians who
after demise's defeat will repopulate
the surface and will later become known
as the hylians
the loftwing giant rideable bird
creatures who remain above the clouds at
the end of the story
the chica an ancient tribe who are
described as the guardians and servants
of goddess hylia
gorons beings made of pure rock the
forest dwelling kikui
mole-like creatures known as magma and
the perella
aquatic creatures who resemble a mix
between a sea horse and a jellyfish
from here we work our way towards the
second entry in the chronology
the minish cap it's unknown how much
time has passed between skyward sword
and minish cap though it is implied that
many many ages have passed since
at the end of skyward sword story the
triforce remained under the protection
of zelda
aka the mortal incarnation of hylia and
on the road leading up to minish cap
some very significant events took place
first off a group of dark sorcerers
known as the interlopers tried to take
possession of the triforce
a war breaks out between the interlopers
and the followers of hylia and to
prevent the relic from falling into the
hands of this power-hungry tribe they
are eventually sealed inside a dimension
known as the twilight realm where they
and their descendants will eventually
lose their ambitions for world dominance
and instead live their lives as a
peaceful civilization
later known as the twilight as a result
of this second attempt at claiming the
triforce by mortals the relic is placed
inside the sacred realm which is a
dimension closely tied to hyrule to top
it off the light sage raaru constructs a
temple on top of the remains of the seal
temple from skyward sword which was
heavily damaged during the war with the
interlopers
this temple continues to serve as the
location where the master sword sleeps
but now also serves as a gateway into
the sacred realm to prevent anyone from
entering the sacred realm and once again
taking possession of the triforce
raaru himself enters the sacred realm to
watch over it and subsequently seals the
entrance to the holy land behind him
this newly built structure
is the temple of time which as mentioned
before is not the same temple of time
from skyward sword but rather a
completely new one built on top of the
ruins of the seal temple where link laid
the massacre to rest at the end of the
game
the next event is a theory which some
fans have dubbed the great migration
the idea is that sometime before during
or after the interloper war the various
races of hyrule started to migrate into
all kinds of different directions
for example the gorons who favor
mountainous and even volcanic
environments and yet were not present at
elden volcano in skyward sword
likely migrated to the elden province
though it is also clear that smaller
groups of them also travel to different
mountain ranges
as they are also found on mount kreno
and minish cap and even outside the
borders of hyrule in labruna and
holodrum
the same thing goes for the skyloftians
who also likely broke up into different
subgroups which each took off in
different directions
a significant portion of them will go on
to become the hylians others may have
decided to stay on skyloft or went
somewhere else in hyrule for instance
there's a theory that groos
one of the skyloftians who played a
fairly big role in skyward sword
may be the original ancestor of the
gerudo due to his red hair and yellow
eyes
a common trait of the gerudo and isn't
found on any of the other skyloftians
and either he himself or some of his
descendants decided to live in the
leneru desert area
lastly and perhaps the most significant
for this theory
the first line of the royal family who
are descendants of the mortal
incarnation of hylia
established the kingdom of hyrule the
first iteration of it
and it shows because the hyrule we see
in minish cap is
way smaller than the ones found in most
of the other zelda games indicating that
this is when the kingdom was still in
its infancy and had not yet expanded its
borders
since skyward sword rendition of hyrule
is the very first depiction of the land
in the chronology of the series
it only makes sense that we mostly use
this map as a basis or reference for
most of the upcoming titles
if we look back at the overworld from
skyward sword we can see that huge
chunks of it are unexplored
all three provinces are separated by
unknown territory and it's likely that
the kingdom of hyrule we see in minish
cap is located somewhere in one of these
unmapped areas
the biggest indication of this is that
none of the recognizable landmarks from
skyward sword are present within the
borders of this newly found kingdom
no volcano no desert and no farren woods
now it could be that diminished woods to
the south
east are a small section of the farren
woods but this doesn't have to be the
case
after all it's unlikely that the farron
woods are the only woods out there
so i'm more inclined to believe that
this is a different forest altogether
and mount krennell though it does have
some small volcanic activity on the
inside of the mountain
is clearly not classified as a volcano
and thus in all probability
unrelated to alden volcano looking at
minuscap's hyrule we do see the first
familiar faces show up in its geography
places like lake hylia named after the
goddess hyrule field
and of course the first rendition of
hyrule castle and castle town
we even see the first iteration of
london ranch the center point of
hyrule's agriculture
in terms of races we find the hylians
who are the descendants of the
skyloftiens from skyward sword
the minish also known as the picori
among hylians tiny thumb-sized creatures
who travel to hyrule from a different
dimension also known as diminished realm
the deku who make their first appearance
here
gorons who are said to have lived on
mount kreno for a while until their
numbers started to dwindle in this area
and the wind tribe a humanoid race who
at some point mastered the power of the
winds and elevated their capital to the
skies
now obviously i could literally devote
an entire video to each individual race
alone
where they came from which race they may
have evolved from
or what caused their disappearance for
instance the kikui magma and perella
are no longer around and are never seen
again after the events of skyward sword
so for instance could the kikui have
evolved into the deku given their
flower-based characteristics or were the
deku always living in this unexplored
area and the kikui simply migrated
elsewhere or stayed behind in the farron
woods and evolved into something else or
simply went extinct at some point
did the zora really evolve from the
perella as many fans speculate or are
they completely unrelated
i mean who's to say that the zora didn't
originate from outside the borders of
hyrule
after all we find them in other lands as
well maybe they originated from termina
or labrena or some other unknown land
somewhere there are also various
theories about the wind tribe
some link them to the oku from twilight
princess others suggest that they are a
subgroup of the original skyloftians who
decided to return to the skies
some even link them to the gerudo due to
the fact that they have red hair
and then we have the shika which well
they just kind of pop in and out of
existence from time to time though they
are usually bound to the highly and
royal family in some way
anyway it's hard to keep track of what
happened to each race exactly after the
great migration
and their fates are filled with all
kinds of what-if scenarios which all
deserve their own separate videos
many of which have already been made by
other theorists so instead we need to
keep our focus on the land of hyrule
itself the last question that remains
about minish cap's hyrule is
why didn't the hylians build their
capital closer to the temple of time
which if you remember is located on top
of the ruins of the seo temple right
here
well i think a better question would be
why should they
after the interloper war the area
surrounding the seal temple was
likely devastated on top of that rauru
had taken care of the triforce
placed it in the sacred realm and closed
the entrance behind him with no more
triforce to protect in the land ravaged
by war
it would make sense that the ancestors
of the hylians would choose to migrate
to richer lands and establish their
kingdom in lands untouched by conflict
and just leave the past behind
hence why the temple of time is nowhere
to be found in minnescap
okay so my voice just completely broke
down after this point
so the next day which brings us to four
swords
the game which inspired the making of
the minish cap yet chronologically takes
place centuries after it
despite its disconnected nature from the
rest of the series
the version of hyrule we see here is
actually pretty easy to pinpoint
the game features no towns no hyrule
castle and only one recognizable
landmark from later games that being
death mountain
chronologically this is the first time
we see the volcano under this new name
and most agree that this is the very
same as the one from skyward sword which
previously carried the name
elden volcano this is largely due to the
fact that we never see any other
volcanoes in hyrule
not of this size anyway as well as the
fact that in some of the later games the
province death mountain resides in
is called elden it's likely that the
gorons who migrated to this mountain
some time after skyward sword
are the ones responsible for renaming it
from eldon volcano to death mountain
since it had since become their
territory after all due to the presence
of death mountain here and its absence
in minish cap we can determine that this
game takes place outside the original
borders of the kingdom of hyrule so
either the kingdom has expanded its
borders to the north towards that
mountain since then or these
incarnations of linc and zelda are
venturing beyond the borders during
their quest
which would explain why there's no towns
or settlements we also see no trace of
farron woods or the leneru desert so
this is definitely a mere fraction of
the world we saw in skyward sword
all other locations like the sea of
trees and talus cave are areas never
before seen in any other game and never
make a return later down the line
and thus carry no real weight on
hyrule's history in the anniversary
edition of four swords there's an
additional area called the realm of
memories
but this is confirmed to be nothing but
an illusory realm where the memories of
events from future and past games are
stored
basically a cheap excuse to play stages
from other zelda titles and
nothing more next up is the big one the
game which by far has the greatest
impact on the future of hyrule and its
inhabitants ocarina of time
it is told by one of the game's
backstories that sometime between the
events of four swords and ocarina
another great war broke out however this
war is not about the triforce but rather
about territory over the span of the
many ages since skyward sword you had
all these different civilizations living
segregated from each other
the zoras emerged and established their
own domain in the east
the gorons to the north who built large
cities and dominated the elden region
and suddenly you had these desert
dwellers to the west who were also
growing in numbers
building settlements and even
establishing their own religion and
culture
and as you remember the original kingdom
of hyrule that being the one from minish
cap was relatively small and its borders
didn't cross into other territories
so for countless years you had these
large civilizations thriving independent
from each other
four big regional powers coexisting side
by side
and what does any kingdom or regional
power want exactly
expand more people means bigger demand
for housing more resources and thus
more land suddenly these big
civilizations are on each other's
doorstep
borders start overlapping so obviously
the inevitable happens
tensions boil over and conflict breaks
out thus starting the hyrulean civil war
if we are to believe the stories this
war was one of the most brutal conflicts
in hyrule's history
perhaps only rivaled by demise's
genocide during the rise of the demon
tribe before the events of skyward sword
this conflict gave birth to places like
the shadow temple where prisoners of war
were tortured by the shika a tribe of
warriors and assassins who operated from
the shadow on behalf of the royal family
of hyrule
we only ever saw one of them throughout
history so far that being impa from
skyward sword and though they remained
absent until now it's clear that they
always remained in close contact with
the royal family
and here they are back again willing to
serve the royal bloodline of goddess
hylia
and in the most brutal way possible this
war lasted all the way up right before
the events of ocarina of time
among the casualties of this conflict
were link's parents
which is when his mortally wounded
mother leaves the boy in the care of the
great deku tree of the forest before
passing away
so when we start link's adventure in the
game the war has only been resolved for
a couple of years
at some point while link was growing up
in the kokiri forest the kingdom of
hyrule eventually emerged victorious
faced with defeat at the hands of the
dominant kingdom the leaders of the
three remaining regional powers the
gorons
zora and gerudo swore loyalty to the
king and their territories were absorbed
into the now
unified kingdom of hyrule among these
leaders was ganondorf the king of the
gerudo
also known as the king of thieves peace
returned to the land however
this was short-lived bitter then
humiliated by his defeat at the hands of
the royal family ganondorf devised the
scheme to take possession of the
triforce which still remains sealed
inside the sacred realm behind the door
of time inside the temple of time
and despite his inevitable defeat and
sealing away at the end of the game
ganondorf is actually successful at
obtaining the triforce
however as per the rules of the triforce
if someone with an evil heart attempts
to obtain it the relic splits into three
different pieces
and only the part that reflects their
personality and desires remains with
that individual
the two remaining parts are then
bestowed upon two other individuals who
reflect each piece's virtue
the triforce of power remains with
ganondorf wisdom landing on zelda
and courage on link despite not
possessing the full triforce the power
of this individual peace does allow
ganondorf to become the king of evil
and with his newfound power invades
hyrule and takes control of the seat of
power killing the king in the process
it also grants him the ability to
transform into his giant bore-like
alter-ego
ganon so now it's time to take a look at
the actual map of ocarina of time first
off we see the first iteration of
kakariko village
a village originally founded and
inhabited by the shika but because most
of them were killed during the war it's
now inhabited by hylians instead
but the most important thing worth
noting is of course the return
of the temple of time which if we
remember from the minish cap era was not
present in that game likely because of
the migration of the hylians after the
interloper war meaning that at some
point between minish cap and ocarina of
time the hylians returned back to the
land of their
distant ancestors it's possible that as
hyrule started expanding its borders in
the run-up to the hyrulean civil war
they stumbled upon the old lands to the
south of the original capital
and decided to move their capital back
to the land of their origin
close to the temple of time because of
the presence of this holy temple we can
easily pinpoint where ocarina of time's
capital is located on skyward swords map
which is here since this is where the
temple of time was constructed by rauru
if we compare the two maps we can see
that there are some strong resemblances
in the geography
the forest to the south east death
mountain to the north and the desert to
the west
all relatively consistent with their
locations from the era of the sky but
there are some inconsistencies as well
for instance lake hylia which was last
seen in the minish cap
used to be to the east of the capital
yet here it's located to the south west
similarly long long range also last seen
in the minish cap was also located to
the east right beside lake hylia
and is now found in the middle of hyrule
field farron woods doesn't seem to exist
and instead we find the lost woods with
the kokiri forest tucked away inside it
and although death mountain does lie
above the capital
its position isn't perfect in skyward
sword the volcano lies straight to the
north
of the seal temple whereas in ocarina of
time it lies considerably closer to the
castle and has shifted to the north
east in order to explain these
inconsistencies we need to talk about
two different aspects
plate tectonics and geographical
renaming plate tectonics kinda speaks
for itself which is the idea that the
provinces of hyrule slowly change
locations over time
this is something that happens in real
life as well our planet's crust is made
up of fragments also known as tectonic
plates
these plates are in constant motion some
moving as fast as 15 centimeters or
close to 6
inches a year this doesn't seem like
much but given enough time this can
drastically change a landscape
for instance 200 million years ago the
earth looked like this
200 million years seems like a lot but
if we compare this to the actual age of
the planet which is four and a half
billion years
200 million is nothing knowing all of
this it really isn't all that crazy to
think that hyrule undergoes the same
type of changes over
time the events of skyward sword and
minish cap alone already take place many
many ages apart from each other
so you can imagine just how much time
has passed by the time ocarina of time
comes along
a strong indication that plate tectonics
do indeed occur in hyrule is the
presence of death mountain
the borders where tectonic plates meet
also known as fault lines
commonly have a lot of volcanic activity
in fact the large majority of earth's
volcanoes are located close to these
faults because well
that's where all the action is as plates
crash into each other they create cracks
and creases in the surface
allowing for molten rock to pass through
the crust thus creating volcanoes
this phenomena could explain why certain
locations slightly shift directions
throughout the timeline and why in this
case death mountain is no longer located
in the exact same location as it was in
skyward sword over the many years it
slowly moved southeast
closer to the sealed grounds of course
plate tectonics can't explain
all changes in hyrule's geography if the
change of a location is too drastic
relative to the others
for instance if the lost woods would all
of a sudden be located completely on the
other side of the map yet
other locations remain the same this
explanation won't do
next we have geographical renaming and
we will use lake hylia as an example
it's easy to assume that the lake hylia
found in ocarina of time and the one
from minish cap are not at all the same
location
it simply doesn't match so then why do
they have the same name
well whenever the hylians settle
somewhere new or in this case return to
the land they left behind ages ago
obviously they're gonna start naming
things and as most civilizations do
these names are usually derived from
their own culture and beliefs
things they know from their own
mythology similar to how in real life we
name the planets of the solar system
after greek gods or how in cities we
name streets and boulevards after famous
authors historical figures or other
people or events
things that had an impact and defy our
culture in some way
so whenever the hylians settle somewhere
and they find a big lake in the area
obviously they're gonna call it lake
hylia hylia of course being the most
dominant figure in their religion and
mythology
the lake usually serves as an important
source of the kingdom's drinking water
and thus they are largely dependent on
it when it comes to their survival
so it's only fitting that they name it
after one of their most sacred deities
in a sense it's like a tradition by that
definition this also explains long long
range
obviously it's not the same range as the
one from minish cap
it's just a name a place that represents
the heart of their agriculture
the large fields and barons surrounding
the capital will always be named hyrule
field
you get the point so what about names
like eldon
farron and leneru whatever happened to
those
well who's to say that this isn't what
they're called in this era the map in
ocarina of time doesn't use province
names
only names of specific landmarks it's
entirely possible
that the death mountain area is in fact
called elden and that the lost woods are
part of the farron province
it's just that nobody in the game uses
the names of these provinces
we can even see this later down the line
in twilight princess
where the lost woods and farron woods
are closely connected
as for the gerudo desert no longer being
called the la neru desert that too
is easily explained la neru is a name
derived from hylian mythology
however the hylians haven't been present
in the desert area ever since the great
migration
instead this new civilization the gerudo
have been living in these wastes for
ages
a civilization which developed its own
culture so obviously they're gonna want
to name their homeland after something
related to them
hence it became known as the gerudo
desert and lost the la neru name
and while we're on the topic of naming
things we also have to remember that the
hylians returned to these parts of
hyrule after ages of living somewhere
else
so it's entirely possible that a lot of
the old place names like farron woods
have
simply been forgotten since then instead
they find a big forest which is easy to
get lost in and they simply call it
the lost woods and lastly we also need
to keep in mind that places like the
forest desert and mountains
are likely but a fraction of the whole
province just because the maps borders
end
doesn't mean that there isn't a whole
lot more forest desert and mountains and
fields beyond the visible borders which
explains why places like the gerudo
desert are so small compared to the vast
laneeru desert from skyward sword
there's probably a whole lot more desert
beyond the desert colossus
and that concludes part 1 of our journey
through hyrule's long history and its
geography
you heard that right this is the start
of a new miniseries which will consist
of four more episodes
because honestly this subject is way too
extensive for one single video
this episode covered the unified
timeline and in the next we will be
covering the first of the three timeline
branches taking place after the timeline
split at the end of ocarina of time
that being the downfall timeline but
before rounding up i have a very
very special mention as this is not just
a regular video
oh no this is actually a special
christmas episode devoted to two
or should i say three fans of the
channel a very merry christmas to
elijah and dominic celso your father
jonathan requested this special episode
just for you guys
and the idea and subject for this
episode was entirely his idea
i hope you have some great holidays
together and thank you so much for
giving me the honor to make a video like
this
so again thank you to elijah dominic and
their father jonathan
man i wish i had a dad who was a zelda
fan you guys
are very lucky and you can truly see
that these guys are real adventurers
you got your campfire you got your tent
that is just
awesome anyway that is all for now a
merry christmas to everyone else
a special thanks to my patreons and i
hope you will join me in the next
episode for some more detective work and
puzzling together the rich history of
hyrule
this is dawn signing off and have a good
[Music]
one
[Music]
do
[Music]
you